getting hold of the agenda so i can send
it as a pdf
so would you like us to go live now
we are now live are we okay well first
of all
apologies for absence yes chair we've
received one apology and that's from
councillor lilly
northeast derbyshire thank you item two
declarations of interest
any declarations uh none have been
received chair
okeydoke item three the minutes of the
last meeting
i guess you presume you've all read
those um are they all correct
any alterations need to be made
no can somebody move those as a correct
record please
um they were in the pack um so
unfortunately so
i've done a page i've actually received
a hard copy but they are actually
on the publish pack um i can confirm my
talent i'm looking at them on screen now
so from our point of view i mean um are
there two members who are actually at
the meeting i think councillor
tate and uh councillor finesse were both
there
i'm happy to move them as a correct
record
council tate would you want a second
we need a second second um sorry
i was on okay yeah thank you thank you
um so they've been approved any matters
arising from the minutes
there's nothing down on here i haven't
got anything
no
okay we'll move on to item four the
quarter report of the joint ict service
quarter three 20 20 to 21.
uh nikki please over to you hello
everybody
um just i'll just provide you with a
summary of the quarterly service report
for the joint ict service it covers
quarter three which covers the period of
october last year to december
2020. i'm sure you're all familiar with
the format by now
the first two graphs show the number of
service requests and incidents the
has received over the last quarter and
the key points to note are that the
service is receiving on average 275 more
requests or incidents per month
compared to what we were getting last
year the increase is directly linked to
additional demand being put on the
service due to
growing a virus outbreak and the new
ways of working
um the next two graphs show the number
of outstanding calls
and these are ones which are yet to be
resolved
key points to note are that the number
of outstanding calls has remained
consistently high
since march last year and the majority
of the outstanding calls are for service
requests
which are the requests for additional
pieces of work rather than
incidents which are to fix something
which is which is broken
and the high number of outstanding calls
is likely to have an impact on the
service need
service meeting its sla targets in the
future
as these older calls get closed it will
increase the number of calls which fail
the sla
the next graph um shows the key
performance
indicator which shows a number of
incidents also this request
closed within a target time as
anticipated the sla was breached for
derbyshire dallas and rickmold in
november
but it was only by less than one percent
and
in north at northeast um it reached by
7.6
in december the sla target for first
time fixed resolution times was exceeded
throughout
throughout the quarter despite the
additional demands placed on service
since march
the joint ict service has not yet not
received any complaints from officers
feedback from the user groups service
managers and service
senior management has been very positive
and complementary
as those services which can be provided
remotely have been given the tools to do
so
the bi-annual joint ictc user survey is
currently in progress
and that should provide us with more
feedback further feedback
and will help determine where resources
need to be focused going forward
if we moved to the outages section of
the report
um there were no priority one outages
over the period
there were 22 priority two outages this
was down from the last quarter
when we do get an outage whether it's
priority one a priority two
each outage is diagnosed and any
recommendations to prevent future
outages
or improve our response to these are
discussed and actioned as necessary
regarding project resource utilization
in the report
um the percentage of time spent on
project related work has been high over
the last quarter
with an average percentage of 38.6
and majority of the work being completed
on joint ict
projects which have been progressed for
all three authorities
a summary of the projects has been given
on the report
and a description of each project has
been added to the project register in
appendix 2 for clarity
moving on to the budget
employee costs um the restructure costs
have now
all been included also there were some
vacancies
due to internal recruitments um which
has impacted
the employee costs regarding transport
transport is
um reduced um due to
reduced travel due to covid19
and regards income there's some further
internal recharges to
be completed
on the cost savings plan and we're still
in progress
with um we've got a tender in progress
to move
northeast telephony to sit and this will
provide
savings for north east and there's also
we're currently progressing the new
joint internet connection which will
deliver cost savings
um of approximately three thousand
pounds per year
and the improved internet bandwidth
although this will not be realized until
september
september 2021 when the other
link expires
regarding the security report there were
no reportable
security incidents logged
and service deliver development um
we've had a few recruitments in the
section to back hill post which have
become vacant
um we have recently altered one of the
service test posts to a remote engineer
post this is to assist with the
additional support requirements for
remote sites
and home workers it should provide
better consistency and
improve the service to support these
requests
well has anyone got any questions around
the report
uh yes thank you very much nikki i've
got several questions
actually that before i uh i'll pass it
out then to the others
uh so i'll ask my questions first if
that's okay
um on page page three
um on page three on incident resolved
why was there a big derby deals dip in
may last year
it sort of drops down to zero
you know what the reason it's 70. it
drops down to 70 percent
oh okay yeah i i'd have to interrogate
the
the figures to find out but i can come
back to you with that
okay that's great thank you um on
page six page six it looks as though
derbyshire dales are ahead on this i
mean we've got so many more projects
uh on the go um or is it is it just
because we have more projects
we seem to be ahead on it
let me just get to page six
um yeah it depends throughout the year
depending on what
projects are um applicable
to your service at the minute you
obviously have the cloud telephony which
is quite a big project
um in progress which which has has been
pushed through because of the covert
demands
um to to change the telephony system
the sid the internet replacement one
that's been completed
and the economic development website
creation that one's in progress at the
moment
the i've sort of highlighted the
projects that are the main projects for
those departments
for each authority on there um
so it does that answer your question or
is it yes it does i mean that's that's
it's basically it's just you know it's
different projects isn't it
yeah different times of the year there's
different projects and some may require
more resources than others
and for instance cloud and there's been
quite a lot of resource
on that one um whereas um
the tech one at the moment we're not
doing as much
work on that one
yeah they sort of just they're broken
down if you look at the project register
that also gives you a bit more
information
yeah okay on page seven
the budget um why are there such big
variances particularly on services
93 000 variants there yeah it's normally
after
they call it reprofiling it's because we
may have a bill
in at a certain time which which lasts
for the whole of the year
and so we may not have been billed for
everything
um up till up to the end of the year we
also
rely on finance to move the um
appropriate amount of budget into the
right year so we maybe
billed for something that in say
if we built for something now um will be
billed for 12 months but only
three months of it is to go into this
year
financial year and the rest ends up in
the next financial year so it does sort
of skew these figures a little bit until
that's
resolved at the end of the year okay so
it should come into balance by the year
end you reckon
okay on page 20 uh we're talking about
um the 365. we've used moving to 365.
um is there will 365 work okay on the on
the apple ipads
um it will do it does have um it does
have
apps which will work on the ipads as
well um but it's something we're going
to work closely with governance and
um james mclaughlin at davis shidells to
establish what it is that members want
and how members use it so that it's
um functional for for what you need
okay now i'm a governor of two schools
two separate schools
and i have to use different browsers for
each 365 account would i
therefore need a third browser for the
district council
or is that covered by the by apple
um you would you'd have an app on your
iphone device
it'd be an app rather than going to the
yeah
rather than going to an internet browser
i think normally
i'm not sure why they're using different
browsers but it may be because it caches
some of your information
so if you log on to one it remembers
that you've logged on to it and yeah
you have to log out and that might be
why you're using different browsers i'm
not sure
what it is if you try and use the same
browser the information will
just get scrambled yeah it's ridiculous
i think if you're using cognito mode
that can help on
chrome because it doesn't remember some
of your settings but
but yeah that's something we will
obviously look into as we progress
through the project to make sure that
it's as easy as we can make it
for our members to use yeah thank you
and the last one is only a minor one
this is about the
the field staff uh for the for the
census
i mean are we assuming that uh uh that
we'll be out of the covid
spacing by then um
that's that's sort of mine nikki oh
sorry that's all right
um at the moment they're playing it by
ear so
they're trying to put plans in place for
um whether we're still in lockdown and
uh not doing the plan is anybody who is
visiting households they will not be
going into properties it will be done
doorstep at a distance the usual
measures
but at the moment they're releasing very
little information
okay that's all my question any other
questions for great
nikki
no no other questions
what is the cost of what is it because
i've never heard of it before
oh it's 3 000 pounds that's for a joint
internet connection
and we've currently got a joint internet
connection and we're moving it on to
another one
so when that one goes and we move on to
the other one it will provide
a 3000 pound a year saving and we'll get
much more additional bandwidth as well
at the same time
does that just apply to northeast no
that's to the joint ict service as a
whole so proportionately
it will proportionately feed back to
each of the authorities
thank you jeff any other questions
yes counselor tate has indicated chair
cancer tape please
yes thank you chair afternoon nicola and
just a quick question
you mentioned we've had 275 more calls
per month
and what is that in a percentage-wise
because i
don't have the figures to hand for last
year so is it like a 50-fold increase or
a hundred or
um i can get those figures for you if
you want um i'll just have to
interrogate the stats again but i can
get those out for you
and i can just be interested you know
what what sort of increase it's impacted
on us and
will we be planning for the future for
that high volume of calls obviously
we're
covered could be possibly hanging around
for quite a long time
yeah we are monitoring this uh situation
at the moment and we're looking at all
the resources
obviously we're in a period of um
unstability at the moment because
we don't necessarily know when we're
going to be coming out of this
um but yeah we are looking at it but i
can get back to you with the figures
and the exact figures so you can see the
percentage
yeah the only reason i mentioned it is
just my concern that if calls stay high
will we still be able to provide that
same level of cover that we currently
are
that's that's mainly what i was asking
thank you yeah we are monitoring the
situation we've got quite
out some outstanding calls which we need
to um go through and have a look
we suspect some of those outstanding
calls perhaps aren't relevant anymore
because they were
pretty they were they've been fixed
subsequently
um it's just that we're catching up on
on all those calls
and but we are monitoring the situation
because um
it's it's obvious that we have got more
work on at the moment due to the covered
situation but i can get those stats to
you that's fine
thank you councillor whitehead
thanks chair hi nicolette hi
um yeah just uh just to comment really
um
covid's kind of like the world's biggest
experiment um
so what what we can see in some of these
numbers is let's say the transport
figure is drastically down for i presume
that's
um variety staff traveling around fixing
things
in some respects that shouldn't change
if if things are broken they still need
fixing
so either we're getting less problems
that don't need fixing
or maybe we do have problems that aren't
being fixed
or maybe the travel wasn't needed in the
first instance
that makes sense um i mean it's not a
lot of money in the scheme of it but
it just showed that we're spending a lot
less money now which is great
um but yet we still operate
yeah um i suspect the trouble is more to
do with the fact that meetings used to
be on site
so you would have joint staff moving for
instance myself moving between
bowls over derbyshire dallas and
northeast that is not happening anymore
that's not needed
anymore because most people are using
the using zoom
um to communicate so i think that's
where a lot of it is
a lot of people are working a lot of the
staff not all um
but some of the staff are working at
home and so
they're not traveling from different
sites to do various different things
most of the stuff that we do do is
remotely but we do have them
service desk presences on on-site and we
go into the offices when needed
um other than that we're abiding by the
the government guidance and
where we can work remotely we work from
home
thank you for that uh councillor
broughton
uh matt broughton heads of partnerships
a transformation chair
[Music]
oh sorry i thought you said counselor
big big button
no it's fine i think councillor fritzley
um
had his hand up prior to me um but i
just wanted to
add a bit of context to that
conversation because it's not
just about ict um the travel savings so
the number
that sticks in my head i think it's 60
000 pounds
forecast saving on travel for bowls over
district council
um and that is travel expenses going to
meetings
it's difficult to forecast some
undoubtedly will
will come back but others others won't
so it's only indicative but
yeah it certainly is an opportunity
counselor firstly yeah thank you
chairman uh
you know whilst we i'm looking at a lot
of talking heads here
and uh you know i mean we we're okay
with that
but i think you know we need to commend
the ict on what they've achieved these
past 12 months
i mean we're in uncharted waters
everything's been thrown
at it and i don't know whether uh
uh matt has got anything to say about
technicalities or this thing but i think
i think ict have done a wonderful job
this past 12 months
you know they've kept it moving uh
they've not caught any
viruses that they're really for isn't a
mess
but you know i think i think we need to
place it on record chairman
uh that we you know we impose the
determination and consistency of the ict
program yeah thank you council we will
do that
uh can you know about please allen uh
councillor purdy
hi sir well i might pretend also council
officially said it doesn't need saying
um and that goes for all local authority
staff who've worked
admirably in this covid i've just got a
question to you and it might be
more aimed at alan and steve
we're having discussions at the moment
at the council with regard to the fact
that it doesn't look as if there's going
to be any primary legislation
uh in may and that means that we've got
to come up with
a plan b i would conduct meetings uh
it might need uh delegated powers to
senior officers so i think i just put
that on the table for
thought processes as to when we come to
may and i would take it forward
thank you councillor white's ted
yeah just i just want to carry on that
point that's a great point let's
let's think about this meeting in
particular is an interesting one because
there's many councillors traveling from
all corners of um
areas uh so there's cost and there's
there's a climate in nothing more
you know we're all traveling around in
cars to get together in a meeting
and and yet we seem to be fine doing it
in this instance
um and and we can save money and and
save
um the environment as well so i would
certainly
like to explore how we can carry on
doing these kind of meetings whether
there's a legal aspect to it i'm not
sure but
um i would certainly like to pursue that
chair if i might come back to cancer
water that's that's actually my point
cass white said it's the fact that
primary legislation was enabled to allow
us to do this
but that runs out i think it was given a
clause data for something like 7th of
may
given the fact that government don't
seem to be moving to any more primary
legislation
it seems to put the ball in our
authorities parks as to how we scramble
and
carry on with our meetings
yeah thank you councillor any other
questions
or points to make
now i think we've i think we've
exhausted it
well thanks very much nikki you've
clearly had a very busy time that's been
very interesting
so we'll move on now to it's the uh
coronavirus additional and current
demands on the service
i think this is just a verbal isn't it
am i correct yeah
yeah it's just really an update to say
um the stuff that we
sort of promote the stuff that we have
been challenged with and we have
achieved
and the fact that we're still and is
still ongoing and it's not all gone away
there's lots of
technical and and different things that
we're working on on top of all the stuff
that we need to do
and that was already scheduled to do um
so i
apologize if some of this doesn't make
any sense by all means asking me
questions
um but i'm just gonna quickly run
through some of the stuff that we've
we've done and we are doing
um so for all of all the authorities we
implemented go to meeting video
conferencing originally that was just a
trial that we did for the first
three months um between march and june
um
when we found out that we're going to be
in lockdown we then implemented the
midterm video conferencing solution
a guidance and policies for zoom and we
added new
security configurations for home working
installed additional applications on the
virtual desktops
implemented a vpn solution to assist
with work home working capacity and
requirements
we procured procured additional
peripherals like powerdyne adapters
headsets etc
purchase built and configured and
deployed additional laptops and ipads
purchased and configured additional
two-factor authentication to assist with
home working and security
um we procured and installed the
disaster recovery virtual servers to
provide better resilience for working at
home
and purchased and installed additional
virtual licenses
we coordinated um required
system operating system upgrades whilst
people working at home
and we've done many cove related updates
to applications for council tax business
rates benefits changes
etc assess several security audits for
access to cloud solutions
and tender for additional network links
and provision
and installed new internet links for the
increased capacity resilient support
resilience to support the agile working
provisioned and implemented replacement
security products
and working on the microsoft 365
implementation to improve agile working
and improve the security
at north east north east asia and bowls
over
we've assisted governance with the ipad
rebuilds and app installations
we've provided assistance on telephony
divers for business centres
set up cameras in council chambers and
the streaming solution
and set up equipment for the covid
support helpline
and the microlab webchat installation
to improve how people can communicate to
the council remotely
through through digital channels um soft
phone configurations for working at home
the projects and development team um
have been busier than ever with creating
and developing online forms and contact
center scripts
a lot of the work has just been
specifically covered related
i'm creating self-isolation forms for
emergency response back in march
developing licensing forms for pubs and
restaurants
and creating 20 to 30 various grant
forms for businesses
that this has positively encouraged
service areas and customers to embrace
using online contact methods
online and telephone payments etc and
bowls over the northeast have
40 to 50 percent of contact being
through digital means
uh derbyshire dales we also specifically
we've reconfigured ipads and up
installations and assisting with the
procurement of the new cloud telephony
system
and rollout at northeast we're assisting
with the chronovirus vaccination center
at charlie park
so it was just really and there's a lot
there to take in but it's just to
reiterate all the all the additional
stuff that and demands that have been
put on us
um due to covey um and
yeah it's down to really having a really
fantastic team of people
um on the joint ict service and that
we're able to support
all these different um demands that
we've we've been
posed yeah thanks nikki and well done
again you know
fantastic effort any questions please
nikki
i haven't got to raise hand on my ipad
so i'm sorry i have to do the physical
um yeah excellent work but i mean we we
do commend all the way that's done uh
i'm
please counselor she raised it um just a
couple of questions one
i'm pleased to see i think i'd like to
understand correctly that northeast arch
is rolling out 365
first so that hopefully you'll suffer
all the
crashes and bangs and wallops before us
um
can you indicate when it might come to
jobs dales
and note that sid's up here as a
replacement i mean it's a hell of a long
time since i used sid and it was very
clunky then
uh so i think we need to get a message
out to our members i don't know if you
use it chair but
um yeah it's a lot more since i used it
um
and there was one other question but
it's escaping at the moment oh yes
um in the 365 which platform will
be going on to will we continue with
zoom or will we transform to microsoft
teams
i think that's something really i speak
to um corporate services
but regardless i am going to meet with
james um
regarding what they want to do in the
future obviously zoom can continue to be
used as everybody's familiar with it
and then at some point it may be that
they prefer teams i think it's something
i can work with governance and corporate
services
and they can look at what what works
best i know there are a lot of councils
now using teams and they've developed a
lot
i think for the future there's nothing
to stop
zoom continuing being used um
they won't need as many licenses once
we've got teams but
that doesn't stop using it for council
meetings so it's something i could
discuss with them for the future but
it's it's not like it needs to change
straight away
regarding time scales for microsoft 365
at the moment we've done some discovery
work with
a consultancy and to give us an idea of
how much work we need to do to get
things into a position
where we can start um the next phase
of implementing microsoft 365
like i said in the demo the
powerpoint demonstration last time
there's lots and lots of bits to
microsoft 365. it is not just
um rolling out teams there's lots of
things in the background
and so we're working on those at the
moment once we've got
a good idea of how much work that's
going to be
we can start putting time scales in
place of when we think it will actually
feed down
to um changes but you know
to the way that we work so at the moment
we're still in that phase where we're
trying to understand
how much work there is involved at the
minute we're doing an identity piece
which is
is basically put in our active directory
which is all the security stuff
into the cloud so there's a lot of
background work before we can do that
and so as soon as we can get some sort
of vindication of the project plan
to you we will do but the moment we're
still in that phase where we're
understanding how much work needs to be
done before we can get anywhere near
rolling anything out to you thanks very
much that's helpful because a lot of
you members ask me when it's rolled out
so that's helpful thank you
any other questions
can you see anything alan no no one's
indicating church just having a look
yes you have to say something
sorry um i think you mentioned about sid
um
access to sid and i've see it's been
re-launched hasn't it so i don't know
like maybe something that needs
promoting with members
yes i'll try it again i'll try it again
it's something we could raise with with
james or or communications perhaps
yeah i don't want to express my
ignorance but who's sick
it's derbyshire dells as uh intranet
it's a bit like
you used to have eric i think i thought
it might have been sort of
uh alex's friend eric's changed his name
any other questions no
okay well thank you very much sorry
christians wanting to speak i believe
please kristin thank you just regarding
sid i think when that was developed the
uh the requirements weren't to include
access to members so it might be that
you can't access it at the moment
so you'll need to speak to
communications if it's something that
you do need access to
we'll have to look at developing that in
at the moment it was built
to use active directory to get access to
it
so i don't think it'll be that
straightforward at the moment but give
it a go
if you can't get access let me know and
we'll have a look at it for you
thanks very much thank you any other
questions
there used to be a slogan asked sid some
years ago
i don't know bt or sorry who's that
speaking
i'm sorry i said i'm still on this sid
thing i think there used to be a slogan
many years it was an advert see if it
was an advert you're thinking about
hitting sid i remember it it was an
advert i think
all right well i think it's something to
do with
it was an advert anyway i think it was
just gas
privatization
that was back in the 80s back in the
year yeah
[Music]
any other questions no okay well thanks
nicola
uh so we'll move on to item six
urgent business anything ellen uh none
of this enter uh
councillor tate's indicating
yes thank you jeff it's just a question
really
um i think it must be at least 12 months
ago now we
we all voted on um a phishing email
which would be sent
out from i t and to highlight anyone who
may need some additional training with
regards to security
i'm just wondering about i personally
haven't seen it
how did that go did we get any any
results
from that uh yeah it hasn't been it
hasn't been done because of
cover-related stuff it's been put on the
back burner i have been sending out some
emails to
members and when we do get alerts um and
i think i sent out uh such a little mini
training guide as well
in in in the interim until we get that
um up and running but it's sort of been
um put on the back burner while we've
been
focusing on other other things during
coving time
um it's still in in place to be done um
it's just it's just fitting it in around
everything else at the moment
i do also send to communications teams
the action fraud
newsletter that comes out every i think
it's probably every quarter
um to put on the website because that is
aimed at
a lot of anything that's that's out
there cyber security related which which
relates to anybody actually it's
it's aimed for anybody businesses or
personal usage as well to try and
um raise the raise the awareness of it
but it is um yeah it is it is
waiting to be sent out okay thank you is
it currently listed as a job that needs
to be done
uh within the yesterday yeah it's
down i'll have to look back but i'm
pretty sure this was pre-covered that we
also like voted
and passed this to be done um i'm
thinking at least 12 months ago
um i'd have to check but yeah it's one
of those things that we've had to put
back
because of other things that have been
more important
to push out how just roughly how we how
we sit in
with security if we had any any i don't
know what you call it is it a breach
of security um the the security report
is in in the
report that we send out um we don't
discuss
breaches um publicly but i'm happy to
talk to you
um off off the camera
regarding anything um
we as part of the public services
network
we attach to the public services network
and we have to have certification
to um attach to that network it's it's
basically
gives us access to certain things such
as elections
and we have to have certification yearly
in order to
um maintain that link part of that meant
that um certification is that we have
penetration tests
from an external company and quest
approved
external company who come in and they
basically
they attack us from the inside um
and then they provide us reports of
anything that where this might be a
vulnerability etc
and then we can purchase those
vulnerabilities or address those issues
so that's an ongoing process that's been
going on for for
years um so we monitor things
through that um as well as obviously
anything that comes through that might
be a vulnerability whether it's some
sort of software that we
use that's that's given um has gotten
vulnerability we will then address
um patching it um
so that's that's a state where we are at
the moment
we have these reports that tell us what
needs to be done and we
we address the critical
things that need to be done okay thank
you the only reason i ask is because
when we when we um passed this to be
done
things weren't online as much as they
are now i know everyone
every meeting is online online online
and we're doing so much
more through our ipads that my my
concern was at the time was there was a
few
members that um i think yourself or
someone else raised
that had consistently sort of like
answered to these emails or replied back
and we were going to put this email out
so that we could then issue relevant
training to
individual members that was all my
concern and
during this this kind of age where we're
all online now if that hasn't been done
you know there could be people who need
extra training which haven't been
approached that's all thank you yeah
that's fine um but we have got it down
to do because
it you know will help raise awareness
but i am also conscious that i'm sending
out things to people
and especially if we get something
specific there are some specific things
that have been
sent out to members and we get alerted
of them and when we do i then send them
on to governance to communicate or
corporate services to to communicate to
the members directly
whether it be a scam that's saying
specifically being aimed at
members um and any sort of training that
we can
provide to to raise that awareness we
will do in between
um but it is it is still scheduled to be
done
nikki is it worth adding sorry the
national
cyber security center work that's going
on at the moment
yeah we are yeah we're working with ncc
um which has been
um acquired the
um work to look at um councils in their
cyber security
um if they were focusing on bowls over
now they're going to do all three
um where we are we're working with them
to look at where there are areas where
we could improve things
um i won't go into any detail because
it's
sensitive information and but that
that will assist us as well to be in a
better position
okay councillor state yeah thank you and
any more anything else before we move on
no can i just ask alan i mean this has
been
this has gone out live is that on
youtube
it isn't the chair it's broadcast on the
um
northeast derbyshire youtube channel and
also you can watch it
uh as part of the archive as well oh
okay
any idea can you find out if you have an
idea how many people have watched it
out of interest um we'll be able to
hopefully get the uh figures in a day or
so's time
not me as many as those that watch that
parish council meeting
in cheshire will it no
hopefully not uh
yeah okay well that's it then it's just
a dating time of next meeting
helen have you got something in mind yes
chairman if you recall
um we said that the before um meetings
of the committee during the year
uh we had three dates identified with
the intention that we tried to
arrange another one before the end of
the municipal year
um obviously sort of um i think you'd
want to also perhaps
want to get this in before any
legislation
changed on this uh uh just as a sort of
um
start of a tent i was wondering how
members would feel about either the
28th of april which is a wednesday in
the afternoon
or friday the 30th of april again in the
afternoon
uh well that's okay for me what was the
second date
the third the 30th so or the uh the
friday
both dates okay for me at the moment i
mean would you like me to
actually just send that round to uh
everyone anyway and that way you can
sort of check all diaries and whatnot
and then we can
yes yes please okay chair will do
okay well thank you thanks again nikki
thanks everybody for your questions
um so we'll we'll sign off now sorry our
counselor
i think was indicating i beg your pardon
just to let you know there's four people
watching live at the moment
does that include us
okay thank you everybody
you